we're told that Kayla wants to visit a
friend who lives 8 kilometres away
she'll ride the subway as far as she can
before walking the rest of the way first
she needs to buy an Access Pass that
costs five dollars and fifty cents there
is also a fee of $1 25 per stop this is
an expensive subway Kayla doesn't want
to spend more than fifteen dollars on
the trip so she wants to know the
largest number of stops she can afford
let s represent the number of stops that
Kayla buys so first pause this video and
see if you can write an inequality that
describes how many stops or that
describes the situation that describes
that she wants to take as many stops as
she can but she doesn't want to spend
more than fifteen dollars all right now
let's do this together so first let's
just think about an expression for how
much she spends so no matter what she's
going to spend five dollars and fifty
cents so we could write it like this so
five dollars and fifty cents that's good
what she's going to spend even if she
doesn't take any stops and then it's one
dollar 25 per stop and s is the number
of stops so the amount she's going to
spend just from the stops is going to be
a dollar twenty-five times s so it's
gonna be plus one dollar twenty-five s
this is the up-front she has to spend
and this is how much she's going to
spend on stops and this is an S right
over here and I wrote a five right next
to it they look kind of similar and we
know that she doesn't want to spend more
than fifteen dollars so she's willing to
spend up to fifteen dollars so this
total amount that she spends has to be
less than or equal to fifteen dollars or
if we didn't write it with the dollar
symbols we would write five point five
zero plus one point two five s is going
to be less than or equal to our needs to
be less than or equal to 15 now that
we've written this inequality what is
the number of stops that Kayla can
afford what's the largest number of
stops that she can afford pause this
didn't try to figure that out well to
figure that out we just have to solve
for
or s and then figure out what the
largest s is that satisfies the
inequality once we've solved for us so
the first thing I would do is subtract
550 from both sides when we do that we
are left with 1.25 or dollar 25 s is
less than or equal to 950 and then I
would divide both sides by 1.25 and
since I'm dividing both sides by a
positive value it doesn't change the
direction of the inequality 1.25 and
then divide this by one point two five
nine point five divided by one point two
five is equal to seven point six so we
get that s needs to be less than or
equal to seven point six so we can't
take a fractional number of stops so the
largest number of stops that kala can
take is going to be seven stop she can't
take eight and she can't take seven and
a half or seven point six so the largest
number she can take is seven stops so
she can take as many as seven stops and
we are done